No, täällä vähän kypsä. Inhoan uusia sanontoja. Minä inhoan uusia typeriä hokemia. Minä inhoan sitä, että joku asia ostetaan.
Miksi joku asia pitää ostaa? Minä ostan tämän mielipiteen. No niin, nyt, jos sinä ostat tämän minun mielipiteeni, laitappa rahaa tulemaan.
Tilinumeroni on toimituksen piedossa. Kiitos.
Sellainen vempula tämä ihmismieli on.
Kun kehotetaan, että jotain ei pitäisi tehdä tai vaikkapa sanoa, niin sitten se on oikeastaan ainoa asia, mitä haluaa tehdä tai sanoa.
Mutta eiköhän me nyt malteta tuon ostamisen kanssa seuraavat puoli tuntia.
Se on kansanradio ja Lasse Olkinoira tässä tervehdys.
Pensan hintaan, taitaa olla. Soitetuin aihe mennellä viikolla, eikä tuo nyt mikään yllätys, kun katsoo viime päivien otsikoita.
Muutakin tänne mahtuu, aina Ruotsin opiskelusta radioohjelmiin ja muovipusseista mielenosoituksiin.
Tuomo tällä päivää.
Tosta pensa- ja polttoaineenhinnasta puhutaan tuo eduskunnassa varmaan, mistään muusta puhutakkaa, ja kaikki vuu on turhaa.
Tuntuu, että se on maailman tärkein asia, mutta ku kattoo tona liikenteeseen, ni ei se kai vielä liian kallista oo, kyllä siää autoja piisaa, ja on kolareita ja jonoja hirveitä, että kylläpä stää varmaan varaa uvia ostaa.
Onhan se tosi, että se on monilla kallista, joka tarvii välttämatta.
On tullu mieleen semmoinen asia, että, eiköhän tämmöisistä, kun nä isot öljyhuottajat ja virmat, niin niiden voittoihin ei oo kukaan puuttunu, eikäs ei sanallakaan oo kuullu.
Että, eikö niiden voitosta voitais vähän nipistää, että, eipä tasa ihmeempiä, morjes.
Noo, mäkelääri täällä.
Pensoon ja polttoaineen hinnan korotus ja menossa ihan vaan ylös päin, ni näkyy jo kaupan kassoilla.
Kylä pitäis hallituksen tehdä jotain, muuten ollaan ihan.
Tosiaan, jos lämmityskausi alkaa, ja polttonesteen, lämmityspolttonesteen, intäki on kaksi euroa päälle, niin ei tuu mitää.
Melkein voisa ehdottaa sillain, että, näitä pörssiyhtiöiden tukea, joita jaetaan 7-8 miljardia vuorissa, ni otettais ne pois, eikä jaeta sinne pörssiyhtiöiden ollenkaan mitään tukevaan.
Hyörynnettäis nekin, vaikka polttoaineiden hinnassa, tultais vaikka Ruotsin tasolle, ei mulla mitään muuta, mutta jotain pitäis tehdä.
No, Heikki, tässä terve. Soitan täältä, täältä, täältä, Oulusta tuota, ja semmoista asia, että tommoinen kirppaa auto, on kyllä ääri, tommoinen hyvä ratkaisu, jonkun aapurin kanssa tai jotain, että jaetaan.
Sitten ne maksut, vakuutusmaksut, ynnä muut, maksut ja joko ainen maksaa. Sitten ne polttoaineet, mitä ite käyttää, ni ihan ite sitten niitettä.
Täällä, meillä ainakin se toimii äärettömän hyvin sitten.
Sillä autolla, nyt ei oo käyttöä niiku, joka päivä juuri kammittaa niiku, ei mitää diisseliauto, vaan pensa-autolla.
Koska diisseliautossa diisseliveroki on nii korkee, ettei tuota tota…
Ja, siinä mitää järkeä sajava, tämmöise, alle… no kymmenen tuotta kilometrii…
Joo, ei sitäkää varmaa niitä, nii. Pensa-auto, se pitää olla, sitte.
No, nii. Heido.
Ja, Tauno lahti ne Hämäälinnasta päivää.
Hämäälinnasta päivää.
Hämäälinnasta päivää on ihmetyttänyt ympäristötietoisten saamattomuus eduskunnassa, kun haittaveroja puuhataan erintarvikkeelle ja nautintoaineille, minkä tietenkin on tarkoitus parantaa kansanterveyttä.
Mutta kukaan ei ole esittänyt haittaveroa talavirenkaiden nastoille, vaikka on kaikkien liikujen selvästi havaittavissa, kuinka paljon ne vitumia ja päällysten materiaalia tiestä irroittavat,
ja varsinkin kevätaikaan aiheutuvat melkoiset pölypilvet ympäristöön.
Myös urautuminen on voimakasta virkkailla väylillä, ja uran pohjiin ilmestyy jopa päällysteen läpimeneviä reikiä, jotka ovat jopa vaarallisia.
Myös melutaso kuivilla pinnolla nousee nastarenkailla huomattavasti.
Jos uusiin nastarenkaisiin määrättäisi nastakohtainen vero, vaikka 50 senttiä nasta, joutuisi, niitä haluavat aiheuttamastaan haitasta maksamaan.
Se myös tekisi kitkarenkaat halvemmiksi, ja saisi ehkä jotkut miettimään siirtymistä mukavaan, äänettömään, ennakoivaan ja turvalliseen ja taloudelliseen ajotapaan.
Nasta vero ei myöskään kohdistuisi vähävaraisiin, kun se koskisi vain uusia renkaita, sillä vähävaraiset käyttävät käytettyjä, jos yleensä autoa on ollenkaan.
Ja viimeisenä kohtana, myös painavat sähköautot, ovat usein nelivetoisia, eivätkä välttämättä tarvitse nastarenkaita. Että, tämmöset terveiset.
Minä kiitän tästä mielipiteestä, minä kiitän tästä puhelusta.
Mainoa juttu, ku suotit ja päiväjatkot.
Juu, samoin sulle.
Juu, hyvä, kiitos, hei.
Nastarenkaita pitäisi verottaa.
Sellaisen ehdotuksen päälle kuullaan lisää ja hyvin monenlaista ehdotusta.
Ehdotuksia ennen tällainen kohtelias huomautus, tämä sama huomautus on tullut muutamaltakin ihmiseltä.
Oikeuden käynnistä ja kasvojen peittämisestä.
Taanoi siellä taas ohjelmassa joku mouhasi, sulaa tietämättömyyttään, syytetty saa peittää kasvonsa ennen oikeudenkäynnin alkua, eli silloin kun media kuvaa.
Kun ovet suljetaan ja oikeudenkäynti alkaa, silloin on syytetty tunnistettava.
Käytätö on ihan järkevä, tuomiohan voi olla myös vapauttava.
Kuka syytön haluaa kasvojensa leviävän koko kansalle?
Iloisin terveisin, Maiju Junko.
Ei sulaa maksaa eräpäivään mennessä.
Jos lasku tullee tännää, ja silloin heti eräpäivä, niin ei kaikki pääse täältä pankkii.
Ja toinen juttu, että pankki ei oo ees auki, ja jos sen vie maksupalaveluun, niin se pitää olla viis arkipäivää siellä pankissa, ennen kuin pankki sen maksaa.
Etta on tämä hullua, että laskut tulee nii viime tipassa, ettei niitä kerkiään maksaa.
Etta rippeyttä tuohon postin kulukuu ja niihin laskuihin, että laittakaa ne nii, että nii asiakaskerkiää ne maksaa.
No, hyvää päivää kaikille, se on Harri täällä, ku soittelee, nii.
Mä otan nyt kantaa siihen suomen kieleen, ku miksi tää ei puhuta, nii.
Tälleen vaan sanoisin, et mä Mikael Agricola, mikä sitä aikoina, tuota, teki tän suomen kieleseen, tuota pistailua, tai oli sitä ennenki jo.
Mutta, se sanoo yhdessä kohtaa sillä tavalla, että kansakunnalle oma kieli on sama, kun se on kansakunnan lapsi.
Et kaikki kellon lapsien tietää, miten lasta kohdellaan, niin pitäis kieltäkin kohdella.
Mut, ku meille tuli tässä kuuskymintaa vuotta sitten, tuli tää Otto lapsi, tää pakkoruotsi, nii siihen menee joka vuosi tää kaks miljardia sitten tähän pakkoruotsiin.
Ni, musta se oi semmoinen turhake, että nyt voisi vaikka ens voida alusta lopettaa sen, ja panna tämän kaks miljardia pensahintoa, niin tää sitten pienimpii eläkkeisiin, nii, ei muuta, kiitos, hei.
Torpan tyttö valittaa, että tuota, Heinolassa on asiat niin huonosti, että arkipäivänäkää ei taise hammaslaikäripäirystykseen tarvii ajaa 74 kilometriä yhteisuuttaa lahtee.
Ja siitä takaisin, nii, eikö Heinolan silinpito pitäis panottaa yleiseen tarkistukseen, että, ja samaten tän valtionkin, ku se datakeskuksii laittaa rahaa, mut datakeskuksia ei täällä tarvita, ne kannattais läkkauttaa tää hyvinvointiyhtiöä ja antaa kaupungille se, kunnille se hoidettavaksi, ei ne hyvinvointiyhtiöt rahaa vaan vievät.
Saikki kirjanpito esille kansalaisille. No moi.
Hyvä perjantai huomenta, täällä seniori. Minä vähän ihmettelen tuota, että onkohan tuo meidän pressa unohtanut, että hän on Suomen presidentti eikä Ukrainan.
Hänellä taitaa mennä vähän nämä maat sekaisin, kun hän niinkun puhuu Ukrainan puolesta enemmän kuin Suomen puolesta. Ehdottaisin, että hän muuttaisi sinne kokonaan.
Nimittäin, ei hän voi olla, et hän koko aika ajaa vaan Ukraina, Ukraina, Ukraina. Hyvää päivänjatkoa.
Olla Tampereelta. Vuokran muutos pian voimaa. Kyhän mä sen ymmärrän tietysti, jos se ku aiheuttaa häiriöitä, ni silloin vuokraselmis purtaan.
Mutta, ny kun nää iriotit on saatana keksinyt tämmösen, lisäksi tupakointi on jatkossa lähtökohtalista kielty ilman vuokraontaa ja lupaa.
No, senkin käsittää jotenkin, mutta tiität tää sananta. Kielon rikkoiminen voi olla irtisanomisperuste ja luvaton runsaas tupakointi, jopa perustavuokrasopimuksen purkua.
Tää on, jää käsittämätöön, tää Suomen vautta, kukanaan on keksinytkin näitä helvetin sopimista, siis tätä tämmöstä lakia.
Kylää pitää jotain muutakin tekemistä olla siellä kuin tämmösiä helvetin peleleikkimisiä. Kiittää, tule, moro.
Tehdotukset jatkuu hetken kuluttua, nämä tosin kaikki koskevat televisiota tai radiota.
Meille sähköpostitse tullut viesti, kuinka se on kumma, että TV-ohjelmat on nykyään täynnä meteliä.
Voi sanoa, että uutisten lukia ja politiikan puhuja eivät saa enää olla äänessä ilman soittimien pimputusta ja rumpujen naputusta.
Dokumentit, haastattelut, luonto-ohjelmat, ohjelmien alkamiset ja välisoitot, mitä kummempaa soittimien pauhaamista taustalla.
Miksei niitä voisi jättää pois tai edes hiljentää, kun ei aina kuule, mitä puhutaan.
Mainoksissa huudetaan kovaa, parhaat kiljuu peiliin katsoen kuin sikaa puukotettaisiin.
Vanha, jolla ei muuta hupia kuin TV-katsominen, on väsynyt meteliin, enkä ole ainoa, kiitos kuulemisesta.
Anniki puolestaan kertoo Whatsappin välityksellä, katsoneensa elämänsä ensimmäisen lentopalloottelun,
ja haluaisi sanoa nuorille miehille, että siistikää suunne.
Kylä valmennukseen tulisi kuulua myös käyttäytyminen pelin jälkeen, julkisesti, siis asiallisesti.
Pukuhuoneessa kiroilkaa, miten haluatte.
Terveisin siis, Annikki.
Ja, tepi tässä soittelee, ja, ty mun täytyy ihmetellä noita televisiöohjelmia,
Ja, taas sieltä tuli yksi päivä, tai monennakin päivänä, tulee ohjelma,
missä Heppu kirroilee niin kauheesti koko ajan,
ja selvittää, ja välillä hakkaa jollain nuijalakin,
ja en tiedä, mikä ohjelma tää oikeastaan onkaan,
mut kummin kiroiluu kauheesti, ja kaiken kukkurast paitassakin lukee vielä edessä,
vaikka minkä näkösiä juttuja.
Kyl vähän pitäis olla kohtuutakse,
ja voi nuorisonkin kanssa kattoo, noit ohjelmi,
ettei paitaika kirjoitettu, vaikka minkä näköistä tekstiä,
että alkaa vielä, ja millä kaikkea alkaa,
ja Heppu vaan nauraa, vaikka kauheita tekstiä,
joka paikasta, kyllä täytyy vaan otettää,
tepseli pois seinästä, ja katsella ikkunasta, lintujen laulua kuunnella samalla,
ei muutako hyviä terveisiä kaikki.
Kiitos, moi moi.
No Lapinukko soittaa, koska minua vaivautuu Lahitapiolan mainostelutelevisossa.
Mitä enemmän, niinkun vakuutat, niin sitä enemmän säästät.
Miten sitä säästää, jos enemmän vakuuttaa?
Jokainen vakuutusvaksu nousee sen mukaan, kuinka paljon vakuutuksia on.
Elikkä näihin pitäis puuttua myös televisio-ohelmavalvonnossa,
siis täysin valheellista tietoa.
Tuommoisia mainoksia, no pitäis kaikki ohelmavalvonnan käyvä läpi, poistaa semmoet, siis suoraan valheellisia mainoksia.
Ja siinä saatta olla, että joku vansonsa ei ymmärrä sitä asiaa, se luulee, että tässä nyt ollaan sitä.
Se on eläkeläinen Nurmiärveltaja.
Mä olen ihmetellyt tätä radiossa, kun tulee keskipäivältä puolenpäivän uutislähetys.
Parikymment vuotta sitten tuli keskipäivän aikamerkki ja keskipäivän uutislähetys.
Ja kaheltoistyöllä, elikkä 24.00, pitäis olla keskiyä, ni puhutaan puolenyön uutislähetyksestä.
Et onks tätä vuorokautta venytetty ja mulkattu ton EU:n takki tällä vaelletta?
Puolipäivää on keskipäivän aikaa ja keskiyä on puoliyyä.
Ihmettelen kovasti.
Kiitos.
No nii, sinne semmoiset terveiset, että yleisradiol, että kun torstaana tulee eduskunnasta kyselytunti neljän ja viiden välilläni,
kun se tulisi suorana radiosta, niin käsitykseni on, että…
Tehän pystyitte siellä kuuntelemaan, tai selvittämättä, kuinka paljon radioa kuunnellaan.
Ni olettaisin, että räjähtysmäisesti tulee Novan kuuntelijoita ja muita pieniltä asemilta tätä kyseistä veroradioa kuuntelemaan,
että se on niin haluttu ohjelma.
Toivoisin näe, että sen pystytte toteuttamaan, kiitoksia.
No, hei, täällä yks mummi vaan soittelee.
Mä ihmettelen sitä niin suuresti, että mikä on, kun noi ykkösejä, kakkosejä, Vemman ohjelmat, niinku tulee jatkuvasti uusinta ja uusintaa.
Sitä mä ihmettelee, sit näitä ohjelman mainoksia.
Tossa harmittaa, kato, ku tulee noi iltauutisetki, maakunnauutiset ja alle 17 illalla, ni…
Sit siihen väliin ängätään niitä ohjelman mainoksia koko ajan.
Totä ei oo tapahtunu ennen, et se mä oon nii harmittaa.
Okei, niitä oo vähän liikaa. Tietysti pitää ohjelman, kanavan mainostaa, että hei, tällaista ohjelmaa on tulossa, mutta sitä voisi tehdä vähän vähemmän ilmeisesti.
Ihan sairasta, mua nii nauratti kerranki, mitä mä katoin sitten, ni…
Pikku kakkoseki, kahentosta aikaa yällä, ja kyllä nyt ihmiset tietää, että pikku kakkonen tulee.
Juu, et se on ihan järjetöntä. No toi, elämän biisit, ne on semmosia, mistä mä tykkää hirveesti.
Ja dokumenteista, ja luonto-ohjelmista, mut nää mainokset, voit taivas sentää, mikä se tänäänki oli, kuule, ni…
Varmaan viis minuuttia tuli, kaiken…Kato, mulle ei oo. Mä en haluu mitään älykännykkää, enkä tietokoneet, koska mä tiedän, et mä oisii siellä yötä päivää, ja lukisin, ja lukisin.
Ni mä en haluu missään nimessä, et mulle ni areenaakaan näyk, sen takia.
Aha, sen takia, sen takia jätät älypuhelimen hankkimatta, koska pelkätet, tai ajattelet, että sitten olisit koko ajan vaan nenäkin siinä ruudessa.
Nii mä oisin.
Joo, joo.
Nii mä oisin. Kato, oon ollut tässä semmoinen kännykkä, kyllä, et tässä on kaikki Vespuukit, ja kaikki K-kaupat, ja mitä, kaiken mailman, nii, nii, tota, nii, ne on poistettu kaikki.
Okei.
Ihan kaikki.
Eli sellaista, vähän niinkun itsesuojelua.
Kyllä, ihan totta.
Mutta televisio on vähän enemmän vaihtelua, kiitos.
Mainio juttu, ku soitit. Minä tolittaa hyvät päiväjatkot.
Samoin sinne.
Joo, moi moi.
Lahden kaupungin vanhusneuvostolta tulee viestiä, koskien VR:n päätöstä poistaa lippuautomaatit rautatieasemilta.
Se on vakava heikennys yhdenvertaisille palveluille.
Valtion yhtiönä VR osoittaa toiminnallaan digisyrjintää.
Perusteluksi on esitetty automaattien vanhentuminen, on kuitenkin vaikea ymmärtää, miksi tähän ei ole varauduttu ajoissa hankkimalla uusia, nykyaikaisia maksupäätteitä.
Tämä jättää suuren joukon ihmisiä, erityisesti niitä, joille digilaitteiden käyttö on mahdotonta, kokonaan junamatkailun ulkopuolelle.
Kaikilla asemilla ei ole kioskia eikä kioskipalvele ympäri vuorokauden, lisäksi lipun hinta nousee, kun se ostetaan kioskista.
Digitalisaation edistäminen ei saa tarkoittaa ikäihmisten ja vammaisten elinpiirin kaventamista tai itsenäisyyden heikentämistä.
Jos valtio voi ilman vastustusta poistaa peruspalveluja, joita veronmaksajat ylläpitävät, ollaan vaarallisella tiellä.
Lahden kaupungin vanhusneuvosto vastustaa jyrkästi VR:n päätöstä, perustuslain mukaan kaikkia kansalaisia tulee kohdella yhdenvertaisesti, myös silloin, kun he matkustavat junalla.
Kansaradio.
Se on kukkonenveikko, Oulu Päivää.
Päivää, Veikko.
Ihan tämmönen asia, nythän purnataan, haukutaan tää hallitusta.
Hallitusta hirviesti, että kaikki toltainen, pensa on kallistaja ja niin edelleen.
Joka asia ei oo mikkiään hyvin.
Ja oihän tämä hallituksen vika ottamahan on.
Mone edelleen hallituksen tämä valtava velanotto ja kaikki tämmönen tuotias.
Ja katteettumia sosialitukien jakaminen ja tämmönen.
Ja sitten ihmiset vielä kuvitelleet, että kun huhtikussa uudet vaalit sen jälkeen,
että siellä on varmaan temarit ja sitä oppositioa, että kissan valvat koittaa, kaikki palaa entiselleen.
Ei todellakaan voi palaa palata, elikkä tuolta, jostakin on leikattava otettava,
mutta toki siinä pitäis olla oikeuden mukana, se oi sanottavaa tuolta noini.
Mutta asia ei kummanne, tuolta ongelmista ei päästä eroon velikaan, nii hirviesti,
ja siihen vaikuttaa nyt tämä, Ukraina avustaminen, sitten tämä hormosisalamen juttu ja kaikki tämmönen tuolta vaikuttava.
Mutta ongelmista ei päästä eroon, se oi ihan turhaa ihmisten kuvitelle, kun minä äänestän tema reitani,
kaikki tuolta palautuu entiselle niiku marinin aikana, hyppä hyppä.
Sinä veikkaat, että tietyllä äänestäjillä tulee olemaan pettymys seuraavien vaalien jälkeen.
Sihko, eihän tämä voi tosiasiosta, hän ei voi mennä karkuun tuolta, ei voi lähtiä tuolta.
Aina se on, kun mä oisin ois olla puoli vuotta, tämä on vaan diktaattori, täysillä valtuuksilla.
Tämä maa voisi paljon parempi, ja ois paljon terveempi tuolta, minä osaisit käyttää järkiä ja karsia näitä,
näitä naurettavuuksia, mitä saa maassa tehdä edelleenkin.
Mutta siinä tarjottiin sellainen vaihtoehto, eli siis Veikko diktaattoriksi puoleksi vuodeksi.
Nii, nii, jos mä toivallan, toivallan tietysti näin nakattua,
mutta tämä on tosi mielestä totta, kun saisi ihan täysillä valtuuksilla päättää kaikista,
kellä jos nokanko, mutta mistä määrata.
Hei, minä kiitän Veikko, kun soitetaan.
No nii, oikein hyvä.
Jes, päivä jatketaan.
Kauheesti hallitusta haukutaan siitä, että on työttömiä ja työttömiä,
ja sitten vielä oikein paljon hallitusta haukutaan myös siitä,
että ei hallitus työllistä ketää.
Yritykset eivät pysty työllistämään ihmisiä.
Tää, rahto loppu, ja moni tykee konkurssi, mutta se on ihan tyhmää, varsinkin STP:n.
Mitä toi on, että haukutaan hallitusta?
Siitä, et on työttömyyttä.
Ei hallitus ketään työllistä.
Ja yritykset yrittää, minkä voivat.
Tää o vaa totuus.
Kiitos.
Liena nähdä maasta, hei.
Olen kuunnellut huolestunena uutisia suomalaisten maataloustuottajien ahdingosta.
Tulot ovat pienemmät kuin tuotot.
Yhä useampi lopettaa.
Mista saamme tulevaisuudessa puhdasta hyvää ruokaa?
Nyt olisi aika, korkea aika tehdä jotain maataloustuottajien säilyttämiseksi.
Mitä tehdään tuottajien hyväksi?
Valtiovalta, herätkää, ennen kuin on liian myöhäistä.
Hei.
No, eläkeläismummo tässä, moi.
Nyt on kyllä piru merras, jos ruvetaan näitä pieniä, tai pieniä, minkäänlaisia eläkkeitä sorraamaan valtion käyttöä.
Hemmetti, soiko se on semmoinen juttu, et me ollaan nii, työelämä se on maksettu, vero, ja edelleen maksetaan vero, niin vieläkö jumalauta pitää korottaa sitä veroa?
Saakeli, nyt kyllä kaikki eläkeläiset lähetää tonne, pääkallon paikalle, ja ollaan sitten nii tuhat päisenä joukkona siellä, että saakeli pistää orkoja purra, kurii.
Kyllä nyt jotain tolkua pitää olla, tää on kaikkee muuta, ku tasavertasta ruvetaan puhuvaan kaittää.
Eläkkeitkin pitää ottaa verolle.
Nyt, kansalaiset.
Kaikki eläkeläiset veron maksevat.
Nyt, parrikaadeille.
Ja vähän äkkiä.
Kylän sinne tonne, kaiken maailman sateekarijuttuihin riittää porukkaa, ja lähtikö nekin vielä mukaa kannustamaan meitä, ja puolustamaan meitä vanhuksia.
Ei tässä muu auta.
Ei tässä muuta.
Katellaa.
Moi.
Ei tässä muuta eduskunnan kyselutuntia kuunnellu, niin ne on kaikki yksmielisiä. Edellinen hallitus on tehnyt sen ja sen. Niiks näiltä kaikilta voisi nyt vähentää sen puoluetuen pois, nii kavopo velkaa. Nii.
No, sitten, jos nuoria pitäis ajatella, niin eihä tää, jos kaks ja puol tuntia kestää koulumatkaa, niin eihä sii nuoria ajateltu ollenkaan.
Nyt oli, oliko Helsinki Sanomissa juttua hiljattain näistä pitkistä koulumatkoista?
No, siitä on ollut puhetta silieä, mut kyllä myös ekaluokkalle, jos kaks ja puol tuntia kestää koulumatkaa, niin mitä se pystyy enää harrastamaan sitten?
Kaksia puolituntia päivässä reissää kouluun, se, se on, se on kyllä pitkä.
Voisko sitä sit ihan hyvä juttu?
Oi, sanatko, että tää oli vielä joku kolmas?
Nyt se sit unohta se kolmas.
Okei, no ei se mitään.Mutta siinä kaksi, kaksi semmoista kohtaa, mihin voisi kiinnittää huomiota.
Niin.
Mmm, kyllä vai.
Hei, hyvää juttu, ku soitit kansa radio? Kiitos tästä puolusta.
No ei mitään.
Minä toivotan päivän jatkot.
No nii, kiitos.
Kiitos, moi.
Niin.
Meille on lähetetty myös tänne tällainen kaunis ruusukortti.
Kortin lähettäjä kirjoittaa, että olen onnellisesti naimisissa, mutta on pieni asia, joka vaivaa.
Mies kuorsaa. Onko siihen apua?
Terveiset.
Oikein häiritsevä kuorsaaminen tai millään tapaa terveyteen liittyvä asia on tietysti sellainen, että kehotetaan kysymään lääkäriltä. Mutta omia kokemuksia aiheesta saa tottakai tänne kansaradioon viestittää. Niitä yhteystietoja on luvassa tuossa aika pian myöhemmin.
Kysymyksestä neuvoihin, tai oikeastaan toiveisiin, tai yksilöiden ehdotuksiin, että kuinka maata me muokataan paremmaksi, tai yksilön elämää, tai vaikkapa hevosten.
Kansaradio.
Täällä on märkittää Itelä-Suomesta, hyvää ja päivää.
Oikein hyvää päivää.
Kuulen, nyt kiehuttaa.
No, kerro, kerro.
Joo, tossa osti roskapussia ja tämmönen koopin, koopin tuote. Halpoja ku mitkäki.
Ja voi hyvää päivää, ku eihän ne kestää yhtään mitää, jollet sä pistää vähintään kahta, päällekkäin.
Luuli säästävänsä rahaa, mutta niitähän menee sitten tuplamäärä.
Joo, joo, et eikä tää oo niinku ainoa tuote, mitä mä oon huomanu. Mä olen vasta vähän yli kaheksankymppiina, ja seuraan asioita, niin
Kaikki tehdään niin helvatin huonosti, ja vähän niinku vasemmalla kädellä, anteeks, vasinkätiset, niin, että vaan ihmiset ostas roinaa. Ni onks tässä niinku mitää järkeä? Ei.
Oh, ja ainakin sitten oma ostos käytöstään, että sitä ei tarvit toista kertaa ostaa, kun eivät kestä.
Joo, mutta ku ei tiedä sitten, mikä kestää, pitääks aina ostaa sitten joku uus, ilmeisesti pitää ostaa.
Nii.
Mutta justiin, tää, emmä niinku kehitystä vastusta.
Mutta ku siellä toisessa päässä oo sitten nää ahneet, jotka keksii kaikenlaista,
Jonni joutavaa, ja huonoa laatua.
Kylähän se on, että jos tehtäs hyvää laatua, ni eihän sitä.
Tää ny hyvänen aika niin paljon ostettais. Et siellä on nää, jotka hieroo sormiaan yhteen, ja taas kilahtaa rahat kaukaloa. Ai, ai, ai, ai, kyllä tässä on jotain, tässä on menny jotain tässä kehityksessä, ihan vähän väärsi.
Tä, että sitten olisit valmis maksamaan vähän enemmän roskapussista, jos se vaan kestäisi?
Oliisin. Siihen ei varmaan tule paljoa lisää, mut jos se kestää, ni se ei sielutaa, kun ei sitä tarvii vaihtaa mennen tullen.
Joo, se on paha juttu, kun on tuollainen heikkolaatuinen roskapussu, ja sitten rappukäytävässä se repeää, ja ne menee sinne kaikille.
Ja sitten rappukäytävässä vielä en kehtaa ruveta kiroilemaankaan, kun ei halua häiritä naapuret.
Kyl mä kehtaan kiroilla, kun mä en oo täältä kotosi.
En hävyttämästi, enkä rumasti, mut kyl mä kiroilet.
Olkoon se sitten eri juttu, mutta…
Justiini, ku sanoit, että ei kestä kotoo roskikselle, ku se jo vuotaa tai repee pohja niinku näissä tuosteissa on, mitä mä inhoon sydämeni pohjasta.
Siinä kuluttajalta palautetta.
Päiväjatkoja.
Minä toivotan päiväjatkoja myös.
Hei.
Moi.
Runtaaja, siis runtaaja, tässä päivää. Runtakkahan joku puolueen johtoo.
Heparalla ja runtauksiin.
Pari kommenttia tuli täällä Yelen Mammalle, että jos ärsyttää, että samat naamat on kaikissa hönppäohjelmissa ja noissa, mitä niitä nyt oo? Ni älä kato niitä.
Areena on täällä kovaa tavaraa.
Ja tää viimeinen mies, että pizzaa mainostetaan.
Ja se tekee meistä ylipainoisia.
Ja samalla kritisoi, että TV:stä tulee liikaa ureille.
Olipas hauskaa, kiitos teille.
Eikö parempaan pystytä, kun valituksen ja motkotetaan tyhjänpäiväisistä.
Kyllä pareimman tuloksen sais, kun jokaisen valituksen sijan jokainen sanois rukouksen Jumalalle.
Ollaan vaan niinku Israelin kansa erämaassa ja ruikutetaan.
Aletaan kultavasikkaa palvomaan, vaikka Jumala antoi taivaasta mannaa ja piti huoneen.
Eipä mulla muuta kuin aamen, terveisin törsäke.
Teukka kysyy, kuka muistaa, minä vuonna, niin sanottu, vapaa kasvatus tuli voimaan?
Ja mitä se sai aikaiseksi nuorimmissa sukupolvissa?
Mietitäänpä sitä, koko Suomen kansa.
Ja soittakaa kansanradioon.
Teukka on kuulolla.
Suomen kansa, aaretti tässä vai?
Terve hevosmies, oon vai?
Hevoset ne pelasti Suomen soassa.
Ainäki oli vahvana apuna.
Ei o silmä hevosiä jaksane.
Evättoe hevoneja.
Sitten haavakot joutumisae viettöä JSP:lle.
Sitten olihan se ystävä ja terapia siellä, vaikeissa paikoissa.
Ja mikä vielä?
Paras kuulovartija.
Veterani kertoi, että ne kyllä hörähti, ku tiesi, että nyt on vaara tilanne.
Ja lentokonneista ne tiesi jo kaua, aikoa ja sitten, että kerkesivät sitten ilmatorjuntaa.
Sitten tötenikku tuli hävästä pulaa, ja sattu hevosee haavottumma, ja ei saatu, että nähti, että se on nyt lopetettavainen.
Palavelipa sitten se hyvää ystävää vielä kenttä keittimässä.
Ja se oli pottuja, ni häystenä meni.
Hyvää ruoka tuli, ku ei ollut mitää, ainakaan siellä yhteeaikaa siellä rintamalla.
Karastio, hevosi ei koheltu, miten se se ratsastajaliitto on muni, muni, nu, ja raha asiat pannu rempalle, ihan ikävältä kuulostaa.
Ja sitten ravi, tässä oli ohelma, että miten, ne on loppu edetty, ja monet hevoset, ja valtio työnttää sinne miljoonia.
Se vain, vain nopees poittaa.
Tykkejä, joku hevonen juostava, ja se pärjää ni oroa, ki.
Nä hevosmiehenen sanoi sitä, paljon parempi ku huono ihminen jo.
Kaverin, palautettaa hevonen takasi, sille mihin se kuuluu.
Voisi sanoa, että, kiitos hevoset, hei, hei.
Se on yhteystietoja vaille valmis tämän viikon kansanradio.
Iso kiitos, kun olit seurana, ja siihen päälle vielä toiset kiitokset, jos laitoit viestiä.
Ja niitä viestejähän voi laittaa, vaikkapa Whatsappin välityksellä numeroon 044 55 154 64.
Sähköpostit osoitteeseen kansan.radio@yle.fi.
Kirjepostipuolestaan osoitteeseen kansanradio PL 79 00 00 24 Yleisradio.
Ja, meidän vastaaja, 08 00, 154 64, sunnuntaisin ihmisvastaajapaikallaan heti lähetyksen jälkeen kolmen tunnin ajan.
Eli, kun huomaat, että jollekin asialle pitäisi ojentaa enemmän risua tai ruusua, mutta kukaan ei tunnu sitä tekevän, niin sinulla on siihen mahdollisuus tämän kansanradion kautta.
Lasse Olkinoara toivottaa oikein hyvää, lokakuumaista eloa.
Ihanaa kuunnella kansanradioa samalla, kun maalataan kraftista ja lailliselle seinälle.
Tämä on kyllä niinkun päivän pelastusesta, tulee toi kansanradio tuolta radiosta toi ääni, että kiva, kun teitte tätä työtä tällä.
Terveisiä täältä Sampereelta vaan, nii, tämmönen alakulttuurimesta, hei.
Täällä Anja muri, sotkamusta, niinhän ne viisaat väittävät, tehnisillä pitäis olla unelmia.
Ja minullahan niitä on, vielä yhdeksänkympisenäkin, koskaan ei ole liian vanha unelmoimaan.
innostun, siis elään.
Kyllä kansa tietää.